so is youtube changing should you place
your investment of time and energy into
this platform is it still worth it i'm
excited to dive into that on today's
episode and after creating content for
several years i can tell you that here
at think media we are excited to share
with you some of the changes that we've
noticed happening on the platform my
name is heather torres and i am your
host here of the think media podcast
welcome if you're brand new to this show
we want to help you grow your influence
using video and then turn that influence
into a high impact and a high profit
online business now here at think media
we have several different content
creators and apparently omar and nolan
from the think media team decided that
they wanted to come and do a podcast
takeover so they're going to be sitting
down and discussing some of the changes
that are happening on youtube now if
you're unfamiliar with our think media
channel you can go to thinkmedia.com and
you can subscribe to our main channel
now nolan and omar both have an
extensive experience of not just being
filmmakers and photographer but also in
creating content both of them are
actually full-time youtubers devoting
their time and energy onto this platform
and not just creating content but
studying the content as well they impact
millions of people every single month
through the content that they're
creating and they are i would say like
youtube scientists when it comes to
figuring out what gets attention and why
people are watching so we're going to
dive into today's episode with omar el
ticori and nola mo from the think media
team
[Music]
we are so excited to be on the think
media podcast i'm stoked i got invited
to one podcast and then i told nolan hey
we gotta hijack the podcast so shout out
to sean we're doing it dude we're taking
over full takeover uh and if you're
listening to this and you hear my voice
right now you're listening to podcast
maybe you're seeing us on youtube check
us out on youtube but uh my name is
nolan molt i am a content creator at
think media i first actually got started
about four years ago working at think
growth video live one i did some video
work kind of vlog style and so ever
since then just started working more and
more uh with think media now it's my
full-time gig but
introduce yourself if they don't i'm
sure they know you yeah i'm sure and i
know heather probably mentioned a little
bit and i've been on the podcast but no
it's uh i think what we saw with nolan
it because at the time i was shooting a
lot of sean's videos and editing them
was that nolan had this uh gift to teach
and so
if you aren't subscribed
to think media i would encourage you to
and we are putting out high quality
videos uh that are going to be helpful
for your journey as a content creator um
and that's over at think media posting
consistently over there but excited to
get into this is youtube changing
i know bro it's
it's it's funny yeah we're gonna be
we're gonna talk about youtube changing
which i think i guess it is for is like
the short answer is it is changing um
and it's what's cool is like the think
media podcast there's a lot of like it's
business talk it's how to make money you
know in the creator economy and um and
and stuff you know surrounding that but
like as us being content creators i'm
excited to kind of share some insights
and some stuff that's working for us
some stuff we want to improve on but
yeah i mean your short answer would you
say yes youtube channel i think i think
what it is is youtube is evolving right
now humans evolve so i think the things
we're on are evolving but i would
encourage you um
if you are a business owner or an
entrepreneur and you would see yourself
as that i think the one thing you need
to see yourself as is a content creator
the entrepreneurs and business owners i
find that view themselves as that first
before they're a business owner actually
is the are the people crushing it with
like their content and their videos and
they even value that at the highest
level when it comes to how they spend
their time it's like no i gotta create
content i gotta make time for this and
so uh hopefully we can help you in this
uh journey uh but i think this is gonna
be an interesting conversation yeah and
i also wanna add too like
i know i think media we have courses on
like how to grow on youtube we have
other courses too that have nothing to
do with youtube but
like we're not like tied to youtube the
reason we talk about youtube so much and
the reason we're on youtube is because
it is the best platform to grow a legit
community especially if you want to make
it a full-time thing make it a business
and so i want to like throw that
disclaimer in there would you agree like
we aren't tied to youtube if there's a
better platform for us to be on like
we're going to be talking about that
when it comes to video like video's the
future youtube is the best place to get
in front of people yeah and i would say
best use for your time yeah you know
like your your efforts can go a long way
which is what we'll talk about with some
of these topics i mean what i love about
youtube is i have i have a couple of
guys who are he has this coffee channel
and he's been growing his instagram like
37 000 followers in the last year and a
half he's absolutely crushing it he's
doing the reels he's doing all that
stuff and so are we
but he's not making as much money as he
could be if he was on youtube and so he
just started doing youtube stuff and i
was talking to him and he was like what
i love about youtube is i'll post
something and it just like it's a
snowball effect and he keeps getting
views and it doesn't stop whereas on
other social media platforms he posts
something and a week later it's like it
dies yeah it's done so and just even the
nature of how i know you you probably
feel like you either know us know shawn
and heather and it's because youtube has
this ability to make it feel like you're
genuinely hanging out with the creator
you're watching yeah and there's that's
just so powerful and that's why when we
meet each other you know at conferences
and stuff like that people feel like
they say like dude i feel like i've hung
out with you like i would watch your
videos pause it do something play it and
like i spent time with you and that's
just a powerful thing that you can do it
24 7 right that somebody can do that in
and through your business via youtube
and so yeah dude we are biased when it
comes to youtube uh but nonetheless uh
there's different ways you can build an
influence yeah and just to talk about
that relationship building and trust
like that comes i think from it comes
from time and long-form video and so
what you know is youtube changing yes
they come out with youtube shorts and
they're competing with tiktok and of
course instagram reels but um when it
comes to building that relationship i
would say long form content like you see
people blow up on tick tock and then
they want to move over to youtube and
yes you can build a relationship with
short form content 100
but i think it's so much easier when you
spend more time with that person and
youtube's the place to be for that but
one of the one of the changes too that
has that i've noticed just in some of
the creators that i follow is there's
been this like
kind of
mr beastified videos where
i've seen creators where their content
is really educational whether it's like
tech reviews or whatever but there is
this kind of like people really they're
seeing mr beast get 100 million views
and when you get 20 000 views on your
tech review video you're like what am i
even doing with my life like 100 million
views like i need to do what mr beast is
doing and so i kind of wanted to ask you
about that and what your thoughts are on
that because
really it comes down to two we have
entertainment on youtube and then you
also have you know educational side of
youtube there's other stuff in there and
that's a big umbrella term but
i would say should edu my question to
you omrs should
educational youtube channels start to
try and be
more of this like entertainment style
and kind of
be that crazy loud mr beast and like
adapt some of that stuff you know what
are your thoughts on that i know it's
definitely difficult uh to see something
working at such a huge level for
somebody that's at the forefront and we
would consider mr beast kind of paving
the way for the future of youtube
however
i think a you youtube is uh no respecter
of persons i guess you could say and
what i mean by that is uh that you don't
have to be mr mr beast in your videos i
actually think if you are in the
educational space and you want to add in
an entertainment side to your videos i
think it's about you becoming more you
the more comfortable you are on camera
the more entertaining you're going to be
to watch we you know because when you
think about education you think teacher
you think you know you know you know
board and information and that's it but
i think it's when you get more
comfortable on camera and you start uh
becoming more you you will become more
entertaining and that's just something
we've evolved to also at think media the
more videos we've been making like you
like weave in a lot of of your
personality and your videos and we're
talking tech gear reviews but there's
personality yeah i think that's the win
and then we i mean and i want you to
speak into the more side of like the
editing and the pacing which that has
less to do about personality but i
wanted to like just say that you can be
more entertaining the more comfortable
you get on camera and that's if you're
in the educational space but i think
there's a there's a way of blending the
two in the way it looks for you
i also think every single creator needs
to ask themselves what value am i
bringing the viewer because it might not
be entertainment for sure someone that
comes to mind is alex and leila hermosi
like dude alex is sitting in this dark
basement on a 480p webcam you literally
can't even put it in hd on youtube and
you know
exactly but what's what's crazy is you
want to hear what he has to say because
he has so much experience he has so much
knowledge and so
him knowing that he doesn't need to mr
beast or enter
tame like make it this crazy concept
with crazy editing because you're there
to hear what he has to say and so i
think if every creator can just like
realize
what is the value i'm bringing and
double down on that so youtube's
changing in some of the features they're
bringing out one of those would be this
scrub bar so you'll notice and if you're
watching the video you're gonna see what
this looks like but on the playhead on
youtube as you scrub through you're
gonna see this like these waves and
that's where people are watching the
video and if it's low they're skipping
through that so i think asking yourself
that question what value am i bringing
um and getting right to it right away
and just
sticking
to that doubling down on the if it's the
information if it's news if it you know
whatever it is um
that's what you need to be focusing on
because if you are trying to do
something else that people don't even
want from your video
um you can run into issues i think
that's one of the issues with vlogging
sometimes
is there is no true
you know why even if you make the title
in thumbnail
and and that's very specific and that
actually does happen in the video
someone might click on that video who's
new and they're going to skip through
your entire day just to reach that
moment of the title for sure yeah and i
think another danger is actually
creating videos that you aren't meant to
sustain you know you create the
expectation from your viewer or for your
viewer and so if you are trying to go
all out and mr beast and entertaining
then you are actually going to burn
yourself out because that wasn't isn't
meant so i the danger is in trying to be
something you're not uh and so you could
be entertaining and educational at the
same time it's just finding what uh
nolan said was the the value you're
trying to bring to your audience yeah i
think when it comes to youtube changing
just
the over like the thing that i've seen
them do every change it's to benefit the
viewer so seeing that retention graph
actually happening um and seeing where
like the most replayed part is or where
the most viewed section is and being
able as a viewer to skip to that moment
it's helping
the viewer because youtube they're
helping creators but ultimately
we don't do this without you guys
watching without without people
listening like
they want the viewer to have the best
experience possible and so i think as
content creators if we can put that into
our heads of how can this video help the
viewer and
literally just obsess over the person
who's gonna watch that video um you're
gonna be changing your content with
youtube and i think it's gonna benefit
you and help you get more views it's
gonna help uh people watching your
videos to just enjoy it more and so uh
even chapters you know we're talking
about changes chapters are
uh you know newish thing that has come
and a lot of people are using them more
and now automatic chapters are happening
and so they they really just want to
make it very easy for viewers to find
the exact thing they're looking for in
that video for sure and we like to say
here i think media the creator who
understands the viewer best wins and
speaking of um
audience and it being about viewers i
think that lends itself to the next
topic and that is do subscribers
matter
still
yeah i mean it's it's funny it's like um
another question to ask yourself is like
can anyone make it on youtube anymore
like do you need subscribers if you have
subscribers does that help you
and the answer i would say is like no
it doesn't really matter how many
subscribers you have on youtube right
now and this is really cool this should
be really encouraging for anyone out
there who is um at zero subscribers at
100 subscribers even if you've been
posting videos like right now you have
the opportunity to i mean you just
shared with me a guy who first upload
basically went viral like what was what
video was that so there was this guy who
posted a video and it was a pastor who
uh his title was like i i was a pastor
and i left the church to do this or
something like that very uh you know
intriguing attention grabbing
controversial it made me want to click
it based off of what i like and it was
served to me and i asked a lot of people
in my world did you watch it and they're
like dude i saw that video too like and
this guy in three weeks got 280 000
views on a video that for the most part
had a pretty basic thumbnail powerful
but basic uh and a very basic title no
tags the description was pretty empty as
far as i know
and it it it showed a lot it showed that
youtube can have a funny way of putting
somebody out there um
and who knows what his plans are like
now i'm looking forward to you know what
he's gonna be posting now but he had
zero subscribers and youtube pushed his
video which just tells me that there is
opportunity on youtube if you feel like
youtube is crowded your first video
could
be
amazing i mean your 10th video might be
amazing but i think there the case study
of this guy his name is john
again or john gann uh was definitely
super interesting we talked about it a
couple days ago and then we just checked
again and his videos doubled and reviews
doubled which is insane
well i hope that you are enjoying
today's conversation and i wanted to let
you know that if you want to go deeper
with us here at think media one of the
best ways to do that to further your
online education is to take one of our
free on-demand classes you can go to
thinkmasterclass.com
where we do a one hour free deep dive
class into what's working on youtube
right now and how you can gain
subscribers and views and income from
your youtube channel we have several
different options for you but the latest
video for you to watch is at
thinkmasterclass.com
this video is not available anywhere on
youtube this is only exclusively for our
think media community who are ready to
go deeper with us at the end of that
class we share with you an opportunity
to become one of our members inside of
this movement of content creators making
a difference in the world so go to
thinkmasterclass.com right now to get
signed up for your free one hour youtube
on demand class now let's get back into
today's featured content
what i'd say too on on that subject is
the like because you're probably
wondering how was he able to do that how
can i do that here is kind of would be
my kind of advice and why i think he
blew up because
when it comes to getting views on
youtube there's search traffic which i
think media like half of our views right
we got like 50 million plus views in uh
in the last year and half of that came
from search traffic and so where's the
other half coming from it's from browse
so when you open up youtube and you go
to the home page when you're watching a
video and you see suggested these videos
are getting recommended you want to be
recommended by youtube you want youtube
saying you should watch this next or on
your homepage they open it up you should
watch this video this guy's video showed
up on everybody's homepage it wasn't
showing up in search no one was typing
in
i left the church full time like so here
is um and i would even say like that
wasn't necessarily entertainment right i
mean it was like story time yeah right
yeah i mean he was just literally
sharing his story um and again it's kind
of hard to put your finger on it more
than the idea that like
had he not got in front of the camera
and made this video this just wouldn't
happen right so i think there's the
principle of just
getting that video out and and and you
know there is a level of cross our
fingers we always cross our fingers
every time we make a video i'm crossing
my fingers it's one out of ten you know
like um but no i i definitely think it
just shows that there's opportunity
still yeah and
the opportunity you know there is
opportunity in search a hundred percent
you that is still a fantastic way to get
views on youtube but there is still a
massive opportunity right now for people
with zero subscribers for people with it
doesn't even matter how many subscribers
but with browse and so how do you get on
browse
is like how how does this guy actually
get his video recommended by youtube to
what 200 you know plus thousand views i
think
first of all he had a very interesting
like we have the perfect video recipe so
that's we teach this in our video
ranking academy course and here's a
little kind of sneak peek as to what it
is but he basically followed it and the
first step is the big idea right and his
idea worked because it like we talked
about it was like
omar looked at that video and he was
like dude i gotta click on this and then
he's asking other people did you check
out this video like it's an idea that
that pulls weight and is actually you
actually want to watch that so if he
posted a video that was titled um
what it was like working in ministry the
past 10 years that's not as interesting
yeah right but i'm a pastor and i left
my church in full-time ministry is very
interesting so like he he had that and
then like it comes down to you know the
thumbnail was simple but because of the
idea he was actually able to get a lot
of clicks high click-through rate really
helps in the youtube algorithm and then
i didn't watch the video but i'm
assuming that he was just engaging and
got right to it and it was like a 16
minute video and you wanted to hear all
of it and those two things matter a lot
so how can you get people to click on
your videos and then how can you get
people to continue watching your videos
if you can obsess about that and the
viewer
dude you can really blow up on youtube
with the right video ideas and and and
even if you have no subscribers it's
just it's it's kind of 100 and i think
there's something like i don't know like
how ninja he was in his regards to like
titling this obviously it could have
been accidental i get a sense of it that
it was kind of accidental yeah but you
can
grow in this skill grow in the skill of
understanding what topic for your niche
or industry would just grab eyes and get
clicks you know i think
it's on you to under to learn that like
what is the pulse of my community even
my future community what are they going
through right now you know when i think
about maybe like uh finances and stuff
like that people are wondering about
recession people are wondering about
inflation like these are things that uh
that you could speak into if it pertains
to your future community that you're
trying to build another thing too on
this whole subscriber thing and why this
should be so encouraging uh for you guys
listening to this is like at think media
we have two million plus subscribers but
when we look at the analytics
our subscribe like views coming from our
subscription feed is so much lower than
our search and our browse and so
it's a lot of people say that's like
really just discouraging right
especially like we built a 2 million
plus channel
and a lot of those subscribers aren't
going to see it now we post every single
day and we have a wide variety of topics
to help creators and so of course not
everyone's going to want to see yeah
every video if you
followed us because you watched the
editing tutorial
you don't need to know what's the best
camera yeah that's come that's about to
come out you have a camera or you just
bought a camera and then tomorrow we're
dropping another video like it makes
sense and i think it's just
understanding the game you're trying to
play uh in that regard and we we still
value search base because that's a lot
of that's a lot of views that's just
coming in
passive views
passive views seriously so
yeah um i mean it's pretty wild you know
that you know two people look two
million subscribers and like where we
actually get a lot of views is in the
long run so making evergreen content
that can continually get searched based
off of a camera based off of you know
people wondering how to get views on
youtube or how to edit in this program
so um there's different strategies you
can run with but you don't need
a ton of subscribers which is pretty
cool and you know
we're just talking about content
creation we're talking about um even
just different strategies on how to get
views when i i was thinking about this
the other day and i was like what would
be the easiest
way to start and grow a youtube channel
in 2022 and i really think if i started
over with nothing and i wanted to do it
that was the least expensive least
amount of work
i would do video podcast
i would do video podcasting and so i
wanted to i know you have a lot of
experience in video podcasting working
with clients helping them grow on
youtube and so why don't you kind of
break down
video podcasting and explain what clips
are and uh for people people know what
podcast is but like specifically youtube
video right so number one one thing i
love about video podcasting is the
format this right here the format of
this video it would be called a video
podcast where you're sitting down you're
talking to a camera you don't need to
put any b-roll the idea is that more or
less the information that's coming from
a conversation or something you're
delivering uh whether it be a teaching
or something but what's so cool about
video podcast is back to like you know
grooming your audience what to expect if
you build an audience that just loves
watching and hearing you in this
you know format then you just did
yourself a solid because i just i don't
i only want you know think media
podcasts to come in this format and and
so for somebody who doesn't have much
time this is a good way to use it
because you could sit down once and
record one episode or maybe it's a
longer episode 30 40 yeah 60 minutes
with with with moments within that
podcast and we're finding a few things
we're finding number one the repurpose
of a video podcast uh number one going
on an audio platform whether it be
spotify or apple podcast number two is
most podcasts are being discovered now
uh with short form content like youtube
shorts reels and tick tocks people are
finding a funny moment or a very uh you
know valuable moment from somebody's
podcast then they're finding the full
podcast and becoming a subscriber to it
and so
that but that creator only sat down once
and created that content so that that's
why i would say video podcasting is
probably the most powerful ways of
creating content today especially if
you're busy because you can spin it
a million different ways exactly you
could record one podcast like every
other week or even once a month
and
you've just recorded content that could
be pulled out in clips and post weekly
uh just by pulling out to certain
moments and that's what we're gonna be
doing with this podcast and
um
another thing just talking about gear is
you also don't need to invest in a super
nice camera right now we got all the
nice cameras and stuff but you could
record a podcast on zoom and have just a
decent microphone get the samson q2u and
it's like 70 bucks and what's awesome is
that's like 70 you could start a youtube
channel use your webcam and focus on the
educational side right and you can
interview people right so you don't even
have to be an expert in whatever you
want to talk about i could start a
podcast about lawn mowing and i
literally could talk to lawnmower
business owners and i have no experience
but because i'm interviewing the right
people
i can almost use and then another cool
thing is you can use them in your titles
and thumbnails to gain leverage if they
have a following and there's just so
many things i love so nolan says he
would do a video podcast
my yes my step deeper would be i would
do a video podcast that was live because
then it would eliminate the need to edit
yeah so doing the live interview uh or
just doing it live and learning how to
skillfully grow in your communication as
a live video podcast can really save you
time and i think uh one person i love
who's doing it not necessarily a video
podcast but the style is ruslan he's
he's just showing up on his computer uh
hitting live and bringing relevant
information to his community and then
just using the youtube editor in the
back end to edit in and out his uh intro
and stuff it's just it's such a powerful
way to use your time and build an
audience if you don't want to learn
editing and as well as um if you want to
you know use your time effectively but
yet build an audience so one of my
favorite examples of this just to drive
it home how like crazy this can be if
you do this is
sean actually went on the creative
disruption podcast and oh yeah i
remember this
like years ago a couple years ago and he
went on this podcast and i think it got
like 5 000 views or something
sean i went to vegas to film intros and
outros and we pulled out clips i think
we had like six videos from this one
podcast
and
i was looking back at some of those
videos some of them have like five
hundred thousand views some of them have
like 200 talking about the clips like
the clip steps that nolan pulls four to
six eight 10-minute clips
getting hundreds of thousand views and
it comes down to serving the viewer
because clips are so powerful because
and that's something we're gonna start
doing with the podcast channel
eventually is more clips because not
everybody wants to watch a 45 a 30
minute long video when really you just
wanted to hear about video podcasting
that's why you clicked on this video and
you don't hear about all the other stuff
talking about in the podcast and so
there's less people skipping through
parts and that is super powerful
obviously getting hundreds of thousands
of views on multiple videos versus just
don't just throw up your podcast
cut that baby up dude for sure
so wild so crazy and
what's cool too about the opportunity
right now with video podcasting like i
said low star startup costs but
basically the thing i want to get into
next and i think where we can actually
help a lot of people listening to this
right now
is how to make better content you said
every business every brand needs to
think of themselves as a media company
as a content creator and so
being a content creator the last you
know multiple years what are just some
ways for people to level up as a as a
their content and even as a content
creator maybe being more efficient and
stuff yeah i think this question a lot
of the times poses like give me the
secret omar like how do i
i was the secret no i think the reality
is is there's nothing that replaces
repetition
uh you know it's
i i would hope we'd be this good i
humbly say that i hope we'd be this good
after two years of posting content
videos consistently and so i think it
really is just a commitment to showing
up consistently
and you will get better every you know
upload and and that the person you are
today the creator you are today is not
the creator you will be in a year from
now hence the creator that actually
posts consistently so i would really
just encourage you to just commit to
that schedule
and and not to pick yourself apart but
watch it back you know like it i think
when you study pro athletes they're
they're at the highest level what are
they doing pro athletes have their own
trainers pro athletes are watching their
game tape pro athletes are studying what
they're doing and and and their
opponents and i know you'll speak into
this in just a moment about studying
youtube but i definitely think watching
yourself back how do you communicate to
the camera are you stiff are you robotic
you know but uh choosing that one thing
that you can level up with in the next
video over time that compound interest
of improvement will game change your
content
yeah one thing i like to do too is when
i'm watching youtube for myself just for
fun is i'll like i'll just start
watching videos and then i'll pause
myself and i'll be like i just watched
that entire video and that was awesome
and then i'm like why did i love that or
why did i click on that i'll go into my
history and i'm like why did i click on
that video something you can actually do
is go to your homepage and see if
there's any like really cool videos and
then be like okay i'm about to watch
this but like
why do i want to click on this and
actually starting to think like a viewer
will help you as a content creator and
so that's one of the things that i've
done is put myself in that shoes another
thing is
experimenting so i just started
experimenting with our end card format
because i was watching dave ramsey clips
and for some reason he just kept getting
going on to the next video in the next
video and they they do something a
little bit finance is okay dude like i'm
on baby i'm not gonna tell you what baby
but basically you know i i literally
just started this experiment with like
two videos where the end card is
different and then i went into the
analytics which is another hack go into
your analytics and actually look at your
retention graphs look at your
click-through rates look at what videos
have basically it'll tell you hey these
are your top 10 videos where people have
stayed the longest of the first 30
seconds like looking at all that stuff
youtube is telling you keep doing this
and so you want to study your own
content
not just look at other people's stuff
but what i noticed was once i applied
this new end card experiment was we
weren't having this cliff in some of my
videos it was just barely dipping down
and i was like okay this is really cool
and this can help kind of move the
needle slowly and so i think leveling up
experimenting and sometimes you're like
yo this video got five views it didn't
work um you know again it takes time to
on youtube sometimes
but yeah experiment try new stuff try
new things and just so you know youtube
rewards the people that are posting
consistently the more videos you post
the more data you are given and you can
actually use that to your advantage it
doesn't help to post seldomly and try to
make conclusions from that you want to
post consistently so that you can get
that information and then make those
tweaks that lead to giant peaks
[Laughter]
okay well nolan and omar were so fun on
today's podcast if you want to see them
more regularly here on this show let me
know down in the comment section below
on youtube or leave a review of what you
thought of the nolan omar podcast
episode i thought it was really fun and
i love getting to sit around a table
with them or on zoom and be able to
discuss some of the changes that are
happening on youtube it really for me
has been such a great investment of time
and energy and we are just seeing this
platform explode with opportunity so if
you liked episodes like this give it a
like button on youtube click the like
button i mean and rate and review the
podcast if you have not done already
over on apple podcast and today's review
comes from jmva29
they said think media has given me that
push that i needed at the right time the
think media team has helped me have the
drive to reach out to people through
youtube it was during the lockdowns that
i thought about putting up a youtube
channel but it's after attending the 1k
challenge that i actually posted my
first video and i've posted one video
every week since then i always listen to
them when i'm driving so i'm always
encouraged i'm team shawn team heather
and even team omar all of you just give
a different flavor to the show well
thank you so much and i will say i'm
also team nolan i know he wasn't
mentioned there but i love
that we get to be a group of creators
bringing content to you every single
week thank you so much for being a part
of what we're doing here at think media
i want to encourage you that if you've
not listened to past episodes we have an
entire library of free content ready for
you to listen to and if you have not yet
signed up for our latest free youtube
class you can do that and watch that on
demand at
thinkmasterclass.com that's the best way
to go deeper with us here at think media
and have the opportunity to join a group
of creators who want to make a
difference in the world through the
power of video thanks for watching or
listening and we'll catch you in the
next episode bye fam
[Music]
you